c'était le dernier journal indépendant
encore publié ci en russie novaïa gazeta
non suspendre sa publication le
directeur de la publication de mitri
mouratov était le co lauréat l'an
dernier du nobel de la paix gauthier
novaïa gazeta c'était pourtant conformer
aux exigences du kremlin mais elle a
reçu un deuxième avertissement
un avertissement de trop selon le
directeur de la publication
oui il faut bien préciser pour se rendre
compte de l'absurdité de la chose pour
quel motif exactement nous vague reset
vient d'être a décidé de se retirer du
du marché de la presse libre d'abord
allé très rare en russie mais écoutez
bien le kremlin les autorités reprochent
à nouveau agressée est de ne pas avoir
mentionné à propos d'une organisation
mais qui était citée dans un article que
cette organisation fait partie des
agents de l'étranger
quelle est cette loi c'est une loi qui a
quelques années
promulguée par part est signé par
poutine et qui dit que toute
organisation au fond qui est critique
vis-à-vis du kremlin avec un certain
nombre de deux personnes qui sont des
ressortissants de l'extérieur toute
organisation de ce type doit être doit
se déclarer elle même comme agent de
l'étranger c'est à dire comme si elle
avait l'intention de subvertir les
instantes les institutions russes et à
chaque fois qu'on mentionne dans un
journal une organisation de ce type il
faut citer qu'elle appartient au groupe
des agents de l'étranger c'est ce qui
est arrivé à novaïa gazeta qui n'a pas
cité récemment c'est une organisation à
ce titre là donc vous voyez jusqu'où ça
va hein c'est un délit tout simplement
d'écriture c'est un délit même pas
d'opinion c'est un délit d' erreur à la
limite alors novaïa gazeta c'était
important parce que c'est le journal et
il faut bien aussi souligner ça c'est ce
qu'ont fait d'ailleurs à france 24
l'honneur de la russie ce sont des gens
comme ça ce sont des journaux comme ça
c'est à dire que sont des gens qui
malgré les ennuis les persécutions le
risque aujourd'hui c'est 15 ans de
prison pour le rédacteur en chef
mouratov city
possible ce sont des gens qui ne sont
pas des moutons de panurge depuis
toujours 93 nouveaux gaz est ça commence
et très vite les premières critiques du
journal c'est à l'encontre des
opérations de la guerre en tchétchénie
puisque vous savez qu'à l'époque la
dîmière poutine d'ailleurs l'occident va
dormir sur cette affaire l'admirent
poutine dit je suis le défenseur face à
l'islamisme la réalité c'est que
l'islamisme deviendra beaucoup plus tard
en tchétchénie et non pas au début à la
faveur si j'ose dire des combats et des
massacres mais nova gaz est assez ça
c'est aussi dénoncé la corruption en
russie parce que vladimir poutine a
prétendu qu'il luttait contre la
corruption oui il a empêché la
corruption d'un côté mais pour créer
d'autres réseaux et canaux de corruption
donc voilà c'est un journal qui est une
conscience qui est une mémoire aussi de
la russie et à une époque où c'est
devenu presque un sport de de jeter la
presse et les journalistes aux orties
bien dans novaïa gazeta il ya eu entre
2000 et 2009 six journalistes qui ont
été assassinés toujours dont anna
politkovskaïa dans des circonstances non
éclairée non élucidées être un exercice
d'équilibriste pour pour les
journalistes
oui toujours toujours comme comme ceux
des échos de moscou la radio qui elle
aussi s'est a décidé de de ne plus
émettre pour protéger ses collaborateurs
comme la télévision dost aussi qui
signifie pluie en russe etc et qui est
aussi allah allah au pharo au fait de ce
qui s'appelle la contestation mais qu
est plus qu'une contestation s'est tue
c'est une réponse nécessaire aux
mensonges et oui c'est toujours du du de
l'équilibrisme j'en donne un seul
exemple
un autre site critique a décidé
récemment non pas d'arrêter sa
publication mais de dire à chaque fois
que nous mettrons le terme opérations
spéciales qui est le cas officiels dont
il auquel il ne faut pas déroger ça
voudrait dire guerre c'est à dire qu'ils
ont prévenu leurs lecteurs de 7 de ce
tour de passe passe mais pour novaïa
gazeta ça n'a pas suffi et c'est vrai
que c'est une institution de la liberté
russe avec tout le courage que ça
implique qu'ils et ils ont obligé de se
mettre en
en obscurité pour ne pas vider m'en
prêter le flanc à des accusations et à
des procès qui pourrait bannir et quand
je dis bannir vous savez ce qu'on
appelle l'exil intérieur en russie ça
ressemble à la colonie pénitentiaire
secteur 11 ans de prison pour toutes
informations non officielles selon la
loi merci beaucoup
gauthier rybinski pour voter recteur
agents sur novaïa gazeta qui annonce
suspendre sa publication